it's just been i think a huge publicity
stunt on their part so what more could
they possibly do than that
all eyes were on carol baskin as she
made her dancing with the star's debut
monday night
but what's really got people talking a
commercial that aired during the show
featuring her missing second husband's
family and carol
well she's got something to say about it
i'm not at all surprised
here's what went down during a
commercial break on monday's premiere
episode of the hit dancing competition a
spot aired in local florida markets that
brought up allegations regarding the
1997 disappearance of carol's second
husband
don lewis we need to know what happened
to our father
the commercial featured don's three
daughters gail linda and donna
along with their former assistant ann
mcqueen and the family's attorney
don lewis mysteriously disappeared in
1997.
his family deserves answers they deserve
justice
do you know who did this or if carol
baskin was involved
100 000 reward has been funded you can
call the tip line
of course the story of his disappearance
was featured on netflix's tiger king
his own kids demanded that they
dna test the meat grinder joe exotic
alleged in the docu-series that carol
killed her husband
a claim that she has adamantly denied
but on monday night while speaking with
e.t the big cat rescue ceo
didn't seem too concerned about the ad
don lewis's family i don't know if you
know this but they took out an
ad during some of the airings of dancing
with the stars
and then they call you out in the ad and
and i wondered how you felt about that
airing during the show
i'm not at all surprised why do you say
that it's just been i think a huge
publicity stunt on their part so what
more could they possibly do than that
anything you would have to say to them
no anything you'd have to say to anybody
who's seen that ad i haven't seen the ad
what do you have to say to the critics
out there of you
find something to do that's worthwhile
with your life
spending time worrying about what i'm
doing is probably not a real good use of
your time
how do you feel it all
i'm just i'm not worried about what
people say because
even when they're saying things that are
negative it's keeping the conversation
out there in the public eye and as long
as i can keep that conversation out
there i can keep the cats in the
spotlight and that's my goal
as for her performance the 59 year old
received a total score of 11 out of 30
the lowest of the night dressed head to
toe in
what else tiger print obviously
naturally carol and her pro partner
pasha dance to eye
of the tiger
but don't expect carol to pull a britney
circa 2001
mtv vmas i've got
what i feel feelings tonight yeah she
says she'll never perform with a real
tiger
absolutely not tigers belong in the wild
they don't belong in cages
period and that's why i'm here is to try
and get that message out that we should
not be breeding them for life in prison
for our own amusement that's just
horrible of us to do that
well how did you feel emotionally uh
carol having
gone on this journey and having this
night go and and getting you know maybe
some lower scores
i feel good about it i always feel like
there's huge room for improvement on
anything
and i feel like if we made it this far
in two weeks every
week that we survive the show that it's
gonna just get better and better